mérignac haute garonne le 4 mai dernier
peu après 18 heures janes daoud 31 ans
mère de trois enfants est assassiné par
son mari celui-ci après l'avoir attendu
toute la journée devant leur domicile
lui tire dans les jambes en pleine rue
avant de l'immoler par le feu chahinez
avait déjà eu affaire à la violence de
son mari en juin 2020 ce dernier lui
avait écrasé le larynx en tentant de
l'étrangler
déjà devant chez eux une agression qui
avait valu à l'époux 18 mois de prison
dont neuf avec sursis
il en a fait seulement cinq avant d'être
libéré en décembre 2020
le 15 mars dernier il la grèce de
nouveau elle se rend alors au
commissariat
sauf que l'agent qui enregistre sa
plainte n'est pas le meilleur des
interlocuteurs à mérignac le flic chargé
de recueillir la plainte d'une femme
battue et plus tard assassiné venait peu
avant d'être lui même condamné pour
violences conjugales la hiérarchie le
savait et n'a rien fait pour l'empêcher
est patent à l'heure où l'intérieur
appelle à la mobilisation générale sur
cette cause est patent c'est bien le mot
car c'est ce policier qui remplit puis
transmet au parquet la grille
d'évaluation du danger et la fiche
d'évaluation des victimes et selon le
rapport conjoint d inspection générale
de l'administration et de la justice
il existe un doute sérieux sur le soin
avec lequel ses grilles ont été
renseignés sans compter la plainte
elle-même qui n'a carrément pas été
transmise au parquet ayant écopé de huit
mois de sursis
il devrait prochainement comparaître
devant un conseil de discipline et
risque d'être temporairement suspendu
l'un de ses chefs reconnaît que son
affectation au bureau des plaintes
étaient discutables
oui c'était discutable enfin cela dit ce
n'était pas le premier dysfonctionnement
après sa condamnation son mari avait
tenté de la joindre à plusieurs reprises
à l'été 2020 en dépit d'une interdiction
prononcée par la justice d'entrer en
contact avec son épouse
malgré une plainte à l'information neige
mais remonter au juge d'application des
peines et la libération du mari violent
semble tout bonnement avoir été prononcé
en dépit du bon sens l'évaluation de la
dangerosité de monsieur n'a été réalisée
que de manière sommaire malgré ses
antécédents judiciaires et son addiction
à l'alcool
aucune expertise psychiatrique ou médico
psychologique de l'auteur des faits n'a
été ordonnée par les magistrats appelée
à statuer sur sa situation
en une décennie près de 1300 femmes ont
été tuées en france par leur conjoint ou
ex-conjoint 130 en 2010 718 en 2010 846
en 2010 9 90 en 2020 ce dernier chiffre
en large baisse à d'ailleurs de quoi
étonner puisque les appels au 39 19 ont
explosé pendant le premier confinement
mais les féminicides sont repartis à la
hausse en 2021 64 depuis le début de
l'année dont certains qui auraient pu
être évitées comme celui de stéphanie à
hayange en moselle poignardée par son
compagnon en pleine rue dans la nuit du
23 au 24 mai dernier à proximité d'un
commissariat
et dans cette affaire également des
plaintes précédentes n'avait pas été
transmise au parquet ce qui n'empêche
pas la mission d'inspection de
considérer qu'il n'y a eu je cite aucun
manquement professionnel dans les
décisions prises avant le meurtre
début juin dans la foulée de cette
affaire le gouvernement a présenté de
nouvelles mesures au nombre de 600 c
enrayer le phénomène des dispositions
qui ont reçu un accueil mitigé de la
part des associations
cette prise de conscience des autorités
est une bonne chose mais cela reste des
mesures est bien insuffisante
on ne va pas cracher dessus mais ces
mesures ne sont pas à la hauteur de la
situation
penn mal exécutée main courante sans
effet formation défaillante des
policiers mauvaise communication entre
services plainte parfois non transmises
manque de moyens voici quelques-uns des
alliés des conjoints assassin la grande
cause du quinquennat décrétée par
emmanuel macron l'année de son élection
ainsi que le grenelle des violences
conjugales ne semble pas avoir eu les
effets tant escompté rien que depuis le
début du mois
sept femmes ont été tuées par leur
conjoint